the former Pakistani prime minister has
just arrived at a court in Islamabad to
face corruption charges meanwhile police
have entered his residence in the city
of Lahore and they beat up his
supporters about 5 000 extra police have
been called to Islamabad and parts of
the capital have been sealed off Khan
has asked for his supporters to follow
him but they're unable to pass into the
city earlier this week crowds of his
supporters and police had a violent
standoff while they were attempting to
arrest him at home for evading court on
separate charges let's bring in Kama
Haider he'll give us an update from
Islamabad so Kamal just tell us where
Imran Khan is exactly right now and and
where his supporters
well you
know
there's also a crowd in front of me
thousands of people have gathered to
welcome Imran Khan as he makes his
appearance in that Court which is also
about 200 meters from where we are we
can't get close to it because the entire
place has been cordoned off shipping
containers have been put in place
five thousand policemen have been
brought in with right gear and of course
the attempt will be to ensure that
nobody gets close to that court now also
important to note that the Pakistan
electronic regulatory media regulatory
Authority has put a ban on coverage of
Imran Khan's rallies also his presence
and Court there will be no coverage on
that and so there is an anticipation
that this could end in violence
important also to note that Imran Khan
gave out a message he said that the
client was to arrest him they wanted to
arrest him because that would take him
out of the political phrase he says this
is part of the London plan he holds
Nawaz Sharif a former prime minister who
is also convicted of corruption charges
and is considered an absconder by
Pakistani law to be calling all the
shots so indeed a politically charged
atmosphere there is an apprehension that
the government is trying to lure Imran
Khan so that they can arrest him if they
do arrest him then there's going to be
trouble all across the country because
of the popularity that he enjoys across
Pakistan and he's also won a 30 of the
37 by elections so indeed the government
is afraid that Imran Khan's support is
growing and they're now looking for an
excuse to bring him down either by
putting him in court he already told
that he feared for his life and that the
government was looking for an excuse to
take him out of the political equation
so Kamal while Imran Khan was making his
way to Islamabad there were reports
coming through that police had entered
his home in Lahore what more can you
tell us about that
currently as soon as Imran Khan left his
residence at Zaman Park in Lahore the
police moved in with bulldozers heavy
contingents of the police they started
smashing all the barricades even
bringing down some of the trees there is
a feeling that of course he's going to
be denied his return to his residence
also important to note that Imran has a
residence outside Islamabad in panigala
that had been cordoned off so it
appeared that the government is in no
new is in no mood to compromise and is
hell bent on trying to create a
situation or perhaps
indeed in Lahore also we are told that
many of his supporters who were gathered
outside his residence who prevented his
arrest have also been taken into custody
okay Kamal thank you so much for that
update that's our Kamal Haida reporting
for us from Islamabad we do apologize as
for the quality of that audio